while they were
look who made it hi dad morning rusty
this family's in a rut we gotta shake
things up we're driving to Walley world
what this isn't [ __ ] right here
my trip to Walley world when I was a kid
was the best time I ever had so you want
to redo your vacation from 30 years ago
this will be completely different I've
never even heard of the original
vacation doesn't matter the new vacation
will stand on its own okay the Griswolds
right yeah I'm here to answer any
questions you might have what's a rim
job
I would guess a rim job is when you kiss
someone with your mouth closed
that's it so you're only using the rim
of your mouth if you're not too old to
let your dad give you a goodnight rim
job this trips exactly what we needed
there was a hole in the side my stop
sounds like you found yourself a glory
hole hmm all right let's hit the road
they see me rolling
I don't know why you want to go back to
Walley world
let's brings up ahead this is beautiful
I say we call it R is walled Springs the
minerals that are in this mud draw
toxins out of your water it gets me
ready
I mean I don't think this is a hot
spring just wanting to make sure y'all
had everything you needed for the night
TV remote okay let me show you on off
pretty straightforward yeah he totally
just came in here to show off his
six-pack how about some tunes
you